you
hi everyone it's Jerry i'ma and chess
calms tactics trainer I'm going to do
another group of three puzzles simply
share my thoughts along the way so in
this first one we are playing as black
hmm my first impression is that this
should be some mate puzzle hmm yeah I'm
thinking it's a may puzzle
I'm immediately drawn towards Queen g3
setting up discovered attacks one thing
to keep in mind is that there is a check
on c7 that shouldn't be a problem though
because after king a7 there isn't a good
follow-up check g6 + f5 are covered for
b6 and c5 also this rook check should
Queen here be the first move rook check
on h8 King a7 it really isn't a good
follow-up check they're actually on
Queen g3 on hook to h8 we can block and
give check we're down
couple of nights so that's another
reason to think we have something really
good like checkmate in this puzzle the
win of material probably not the best I
have yet to consider these checking
moves but that's because I don't really
see them amounting to much rook here you
can always sack the Queen yeah I don't
think it's a checking move I think it's
a quiet first move Queen g3 and let me
just consider mmm let me just consider
Brooke to h8 cuz again Queen c7 King
here and the checks run out pretty quick
so Queen g3 rook AJ I wonder if you can
just actually move the king instead of
dropping the rook back and throwing it
check back Queen g3 rookie a rookie
yeah Queen g3 rook h8 if rook f8 check
the king must go here to d1 and do we
have a mate hmm not quite seeing a mate
our rook would be pinned so it's
basically our queen on g3 and rook on g2
who have to try and give mate there's a
check on f3 which would force King back
to e1 mm I'm not really seeing not
really seeing a mate there I I mean I
think we could just scoop up the rook
from that position Queen g3 King d1 if
rook AJ we block with check King d1 we
simply take the rook and we're
threatening then rook to h1 and there's
still no good follow up
for white there's just one silly check
on c7 so I'm pretty sure that this is it
Queen g3 but let me consider just one
more variation for white because I don't
believe rook h8 would be the most
testing Queen g3 suppose well that's not
testing it all either Queen g3 Knight d2
we take the night with check and then
play Queen f2 mate next yeah this must
be it clean a g3 is there a way that
white can rattle the Queen position when
she's on g3 I don't really see it I'm
gonna go with the Queen g3 that is
correct and they are going with her to
h8 so it is this block
I think yep
that's the trick I guess the important
thing to realize is that we have time
for this Queen g3 move this quiet move
this check doesn't amount to anything on
c7 in nor does my rook to h8 ok not too
big a fan of that first one let's see oh
we could get with this next one here
playing once again it has black ok we
are in check materialize were up a minor
piece ok
move the king we're going to drop our
Knight I don't see how that could be the
answer
hmm I guess
to just block on f3 queen ki give a
check here and then King up to g6 hmm
that must be what it is if we're just
blocking with Bishop here or King to g7
they grab the night and there's nothing
so the idea here is to just hang on to
the material and this is the only way to
do it with Queen f6 hmm we have to be
careful though because there is rook to
h7 so if we play Queen f6 rook h7 what
are we doing there okay and there's a
little bit of work yet Queen f6 rook h7
hmm what would we do there I mean we
could take or maybe even play King to g8
I think this is the trick I'm pretty
sure that this is the first move but how
exactly to react how exactly to react to
this rook to h7 move well actually it's
not so difficult you have to play King
to g8 at that point there is well you
either capture or play King to g8 excuse
me capture on h7 or play King to g8 so
what I'm doing here is trying to work
out the difference between the two
because I don't see any other second
move or any other first move by white
after Queen f6 Queen check here King g6
and that's pretty much it why does
also in a fork currently so queen of six
Queen check King g6 to get out of the
fork they'd have to exchange rooks and
then well they're going to have to make
a what appears to be a strictly
defensive move
so black would be in no danger from that
point Queen f6 rook h7 to capture or
play King g8 hmm
it feels like both would be alright hmm
now I'm leaning more towards King to g8
and the reason for this is because I
want to acquire a position where I'm
still threatening to exchange Queens and
beyond this rook on d1 and that'll
ensure a queen trade otherwise white is
going to lose some more material so in
other words Queen f6 rook h7 King to g8
rook takes on h8 then King takes rook
there remains tension between the Queens
and we still have pressure on this night
if I'm Queen f6 rook h7 rook takes rook
Queen takes rook mm-hmm it's no longer
so clear because
and the queen will be here with check
and if we're blocking with the Queen she
could go back to f5 mm-hmm I think that
it's King to g8 in that variation let me
consider once more Queen f6 rook h7 King
g8 immediately yeah that should do it
really Queen f6 rook
if we're taking the rook white
recaptures with check I guess from that
position we can move our queen but again
we don't have tension between the Queens
and there's there's some fear of this
rook coming over to f1 pinning our
Knight to the King yeah this must be at
Queen f6 rook h7 King g8 is the key idea
and again the end result will be the the
remains tension between the Queen's and
we have pressure on the rook so we
should be blocking the check yes and now
King to g8 that is correct and King
takes rook notice that h1 is covered by
our Knight and this should be pretty
much it we exchanged Queens now I don't
see anything better exchange Queens and
then move the knight I guess it's going
to be puzzle solved after this yep
that's the trick there so my fear just
going into the analysis real quick my
fear from this position with taking the
rook right away was that the Queen is
still on board and our King is a bit
uncomfortable we could block the check
but the Queen returns here looking to
pick up the night and we'd have to go
back and the other continuation would be
I don't know King to one of these three
well excuse me let's say here here right
here there's no good checks by the white
queen but this is a bit uncomfortable
with now maybe this is a follow up idea
this is an uncomfortable pin so
basically try to keep tension between
the Queen's with this one and more
trades are pretty much going to happen
as soon as the Queen's are off there's
no there's no danger for our King in
this one okay
not too bad there that's a puzzle that
really tests your defensive abilities I
believe more than anything or even yeah
probably it's it's pretty much a
defensive type puzzle when that
questions your understanding of uh and
the possible the the the aggressive
possibilities your opponent may have if
you're not accurate
okay let's try third and final one one
more that has black hmm okay these rooks
feel like they're out of play
one of my first thoughts is some rook to
the e-file and I'm thinking it would be
the a rook that really appointed him
having no point in staying on the a file
the F file there's stuff happening
already he's active so this is an
immediate candidate also this move has
my attention as well intersection Square
Paul Knight Queen rook all keeping a
close eye on F for this Bishop is pinned
here's a reason why Rupp DEA would not
be working Queen here and then what
nothing good from there okay so rook 88
I'm assuming that's the first move but
what in the world would we do after
Queen 2 D 3 hmm well let's see actually
the Queen and King are now on the same
file so maybe this is a move if work a
to e8 Queen d3 Knight to e5 attacks the
Queen I'm thinking that this is what it
is yeah this seems to be pretty
convincing notice on rook a to e8 the
Queen of course needs to get out of the
line of fire and still reinforce a3 so
otherwise we're just smashing through
grabbing this pawn maybe even grabbing
here and yeah there must be something
from that point so Brooke a to e8 Queen
d3 95 I believe is it we're threatening
to not only take the Queen but take the
Queen and be defending our truck in case
there is some counter-attack against our
queen like we could take our queen and
then take on f2 if our queen was ever
threatened at that stage of course we
have the rookie or defending our queen
so as well I was leaning more towards
rook a to e8 Queen d3 and then Knight to
e5 which is doing two things threatening
the Queen and threatening Knight to f3
taking advantage of this pin in picking
up a
I believe a full rook hmm I think the
white will be forced to give up their
Queen rook a e8 Queen D 395 I'm thinking
that you have to take the knight at that
stage I don't see any good first moves
and he could checking those on move one
here this is really crying out to be
played
rook AE a queen G 395 on takes Knight
and then we're up to d8 the cleanest
pinned and we're threatening to take the
Queen and then come over here and give a
check and then start grabbing on e3 or
maybe even the bishop depending which is
free that must be it I'm not really
seeing much another candidate move
really just kind of double-checking here
you know we need one more piece involved
it's got to be this am I correct on this
first move by White Queen d3 is there
another option I may be overlooking I
don't think so
Queen g2 we take on e3 with check and
that removes the defender of f4 which
will allow Knight f4 being on the Queen
or maybe even taking on d4 if it happens
to be with check yeah Brooke a e8 Queen
g2 Queen takes III yeah this will be
collapsing because if the King goes here
we would have Queen to c1 mate
so the King would
go to d12 still maintain control over
the bishop and that allows queen takes
d4 check and then we have all sorts of
stuff happening both rooks at that point
on to completely open files and night
jumping into f4 that all that'll be
deadly for white okay that must be what
it is
rook 88 and then Knight to e5 has the
idea yep and then Knight to e5 I know
that's the trick and they're just going
in for this move so we could take the
Queen and as mentioned we're able to
recapture now with the knight okay I
don't think that that was the most
testing line maybe it is it's it's the
correct idea just going into the
analysis here it's the correct idea this
95 move seeing the Queen and King lined
up now all right I was thinking that
this would be best
rook here and then mmm maybe not I know
it's tough like it's you have to go here
to defend the bishop doing something
like this isn't working because of check
and then you deflect the King away from
the bishop
maybe if white did something like after
rook here rook here we take the clean
and this is still winning for a black
but it seems like it's more of a
struggle with this continuation than to
just play rip to f1 okay either way it's
going to be winning and this is this is
the main idea here rook 88 and then
Knight to e5 okay
not too bad I guess with these three
feel free to leave any feedback to this
video share how you did with these three
did you get them all let me know in the
comment section below and as usual I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye